spring in Russell Wilson the Seahawks
quarterback Russ good to talk to you
again what do you think of load
management with the NBA with these stars
with the NBA yeah you know I think these
guys in it's extremely amazing acid I
think some of the best athletes in the
world and you know I think the travel
you know as much as they travel and as
much as they play you know I think you
know they definitely probably need some
some breaks you know they shouldn't be
playing every single minute never every
single game you know but when it gets
down to the wire you know I think that's
you know in the season that's when they
they really want to shine and play the
whole game but if you could take a week
off late in the season in a game that
didn't matter would you do it if it
meant it could help you in the
postseason
not at all when I play football you know
we only got we only have 16 games every
every play every game every moment
matters okay I I'm just curious with
these guys and I understand the load
management there I don't know if load
management will creep into the NFL could
you see a scenario where guys were
taking games off just you know look at
the you know the attrition in this sport
you know all these backup quarterbacks
are playing now and this is a position
that we're going out of our way to try
to protect well I think what football
you know you know there definitely are
some tough injuries and everything else
but the reality is we only get 16
chances to do it and i think i know
there's another's talk about having a 17
game season and possibly having you know
i replayer set out one game which i
think it's a terrible idea i think that
has nothing to do with really player
health safety or anything like that I
think that's more to do with you know
trying to get more games and you know at
the end of the day the NFL's a business
and what to make people sit out a game
it makes no sense when there's not
enough games in the first place you know
if you do that so I think the reality is
is that you know for players you know
you know every week you know every week
matters in the NFL every every game
matters there's no bad teams really you
know there's a lot of great players
every team has great players every team
has you know people who can really make
a lot of place so you'll see games where
you have that team win that
how did that team do that that's just
because it's a battle every week I don't
think you've missed a game have you in
your career now I've been fortunate not
to you know the unfortunate play you
know every play pretty much so I think
that it's a been a blessing just to take
care of myself and you know I to be
honest with you I invest into the you
know into my body and my mind on all
that stuff you know off the field you
know and and in terms of you know have a
whole performance team I have a mental
coach it got a you know whole
performance team in terms of you know
you know a physical therapist wait wait
wait what's the mental coach do yeah so
my guys that Trevor Moore that's right I
do I've been working with him for 10
years so you know it's been you know we
always talk about the mind you know and
we talk about you know how really the
minds a muscle something that we train
our bodies we we can we work on
nutrition and everything else but why
don't we work on in mind and how we
think you know how we think about you
know crucial situations how we think
about ourselves what we say to ourselves
how we prepare so I've been working with
Trevor moet for over 10 years now you
know you work for Nick Saban in Alabama
for a long time work for state now it's
a Georgia he you know worked with
Michael Johnson you know the Olympic
gold medalist several other team NBA
teams the Thunder to everybody else and
so we've been we've been best friends
business partners and and you know now
we have a company actually called
limbless mines where we actually you
know work with corporations and people
around the world and top CEO so it's
been a blessing to be able to do that
and so do you think about mental health
and how guys think you know you even
think about you think about just just
trying to be successful and play this
game you know for for a long period of
time for 10 20 years you know you get
out of your mind prepared and even going
even you know every game you know a bill
write about you one day and you know
positively and the next day will be
negative so how do you how do you stay
how do you stay sane how do you stay
focused on the mission how do you you
know you got to have what it takes but
is this about a visualization Russ it's
about visualization it's about language
it's about neutrality you know not
being too positive not being too
negative we talk about that all the time
being neutral you know and and and and
stay in the course and you know and so
you know one of the things that you know
we always say you know you don't have to
be sick to get better I think so many
people wait to improve their mind and
talk about the mind and you know and
everything else and I think that one of
the things is that you know the reality
is is that mental health is a real thing
you know how do we how do we improve our
minds these even when we you know are
our highest moments and how do we how do
we do that when we're our lowest and I
think it's something we don't talk about
enough
are you more apt to call your Mentalist
after a win or after a loss we talk
every week no matter what we almost
every day six of them this morning you
know so we talk all the time but you
know we've we've developed an amazing
relationship we've been best friends I
guess that's 10 years now and so yeah
it's been a fun Joyride and does he do
group sessions Russ then I could bring
him in and he could talk to the dance oh
yeah for sure yeah I mean we could
definitely do that we like I said we
have a company called winless minds when
we're working with some of the top
fortune 500 companies and you know top
CEOs and top people in the world and and
then you know I said he works with some
of the most premier athletes in the
world so we'd love to do that for sure
what if Jimmy Garoppolo called you and
said hey could I talk to your Mentalist
here to make me better would you would
you have we're talking Russell Wilson
the Seahawks and the 49 years how much
game footage of you watching that
49er defense oh man watch tons watch
every game and just re-watch stuff and
you spend hours upon hours watching film
you know that's what to do but ever you
ever turned it off though because you
you just go I can't watch anymore it is
like it it's to defeating here I'm you
know they look too good yeah they look
really really really good defensive
lines really special they got you know
their linebackers were playing well you
know it's a tough loss with Quan going
out for them but you know they
everybody else playing great and then
you think about the secondary and what
they're doing and then got sure him over
there who's been playing great all
season 2 as well so they got a great
defense and both of the rookie you know
he's uh he's not playing like a rookie
you know you notice how to get to the
quarterback called havoc and making
plays so it's gonna be a great game it's
give me a tough battle and and we're
going to be play our best football but
you know what you can and can't do with
Richard Sherman right as a former
teammate thank you not much there's not
much you can do with Richard he's as
good as it gets he's one of the best to
ever do it so you know I've seen him do
it for years you know and our team and
and then you know he's doing it there
for the 49ers so do you think you know
do you think he'll talk to you during
the game would talk to me yeah um I
think I think we'll see each other you
know before the game stuff like that but
he's not you know I think they will
share a couple works here at they're
just saying what's up and then you know
I'm pretty focused on again I don't say
much you know I'm pretty zoned in so um
you know I know he's a I know he's a
mazing player and you know he'll do a
little chattery you know that's just
that's how he plays and and that's what
makes him so good he he can he can stay
focus and do his thing I mentioned this
on Monday I think when we were gonna
have you on and I said you know you're
having this unbelievable season 22
touchdowns one interception I said you
know to the audience how often do you
think Russell Wilson ran in that game
this past weekend against Tampa Bay and
when I said you had one run and I think
it was the fourth quarter for like 13
yards I mean you appear to be a running
quarterback but you're not a running
quarterback it's your it's kind of
selective running there how would you
describe your style well for me you know
I actually rather sit in the pocket and
throw from the pocket all day and you
know there's times where you get outside
the pocket you scramble a little bit
become creative and everything else and
you know I'm receivers do a great job
you know tight ends and running backs to
a great job getting open in those
situations and you know that's where it
gets real dangerous for the defense
because you know there's opportunities
for us to make plays but I think you
know for me I'm not looking to run it
you know I'm really looking to throw it
there's you know when when
everything's covered up or something
like that and or if there's a if there's
a time that I need to you know whether
Laurel Lane opens up like that then I
may take off but I'm not really looking
to run you know we got great running
backs and Kris Carson he's been having
amazing near penny as well and I'm
really trying to give them the ball
we had Earl Thomas on earlier this week
and I said take me back to when you and
Richard Sherman
after you beat New England in the
regular season where they both said you
mad bro
and Earl just started laughing gigs we
were so young we didn't know what we
were doing back then did when did you
catch wind of that but these guys are
saying to brady after they beat him you
mad bro oh I think they said that you
know Reza's end of the game yeah number
that was my I was actually my rookie
year that was my rookie year we actually
beat New England you know at home we
can't she came from behind it was a
great game and a Sidney Rice called an
amazing you know sweet catch another
game for a touchdown and I think that's
just the emotions of the game you know
emotions take you take you places and
you know get fired up and Tom Brady's
you know arguably the greatest of all
time you know and you know in terms of
this game and I think I think that gets
you fired up when you play a guy like
that so I'm sure that was just fired up
emotions that's for sure do you think
he's the greatest quarterback of all
time yeah I mean I I base things off of
wins and championships so I would say
yes you know I think these you know I
feel guys that I look at her you know
definitely Tom Brady you know I think
Drew Brees you know I think you know
there's other guys too like obviously
Joe Montana has been one of the guys
who's won more championships and
everything else I think when you think
about Tommy you know all the
championships he's once well you know
his numbers proven and Peyton Manning
obviously as well you know so those
those are some of the top guys in my
opinion I think it's been it's been an
honor to actually play some of those
guys you know to to play you know Peyton
to play you know Tom and Drew and you
know be honest just share the same feel
with him it's been a blessing okay would
you rather be four no in the Super Bowl
Joe Montana or six and three in the
Super Bowl Tom Brady I rather be six or
three more opportunities okay
and Super Bowl wins I think that's you
know but both of them are good
last time what's the biggest
disagreement you ever had with Pete
Carroll ooh interesting question you
know I think we usually see I think for
us you ever got yelled and then had to
make up with one another in San Pam
sorry and hey I'm sorry
pretty cordial so alright because Pete
seems like a fun-loving guy but and but
you're pretty intense there but you know
I like you're not the one who threw the
football and broke his nose a couple of
weeks ago right
no that was Cody boy okay I just want to
make sure he felt that the whole
subjects Cody actually sits next to me
and then had a meeting to write to my
left on the front row and he Cody Cody
was feeling bad for himself oh well the
next next month essentially he he
basically had to park all the way in the
far corner you know anything he didn't
get any hidden getting a little for a
good month Monday night at the Niners
it'll be the Seahawks against the Niners
that great defense there and you get a
chance to say hello to bosun yeah I know
I hopefully I don't forget to say hello
to to Austin Thank You Ross we
appreciate your time as always and good
luck on Monday night it's always a
pleasure guys great talking to you go
there you go go honks we were we were
concerned Seidman was gonna have to
throw in the go Hawks there go Hawks
going so much for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]